hey reject nation I'm Greg Alba who's
you I is Rachel adorkable Rachel dorable
Rachel check out our YouTube channel
people reactions reviews one-of-a-kind
we're gonna do a video reaction to we're
interested something from America's Got
Talent
I know I'm gonna do this wrong fly Flo
Jay flowers a flash a light will go with
that 14 year old rapper earns golden
buzzer from Chris Hardwick look I got a
lot of strong opinions about Chris
Hardwick and we're not gonna go into any
of that today this video is not about
Chris Hardwick it's more about this 14
year old rapper and I want to keep the
attention on who this rapper is and not
on any opinions about Chris Hardwick
just Sarah now I do have some strong
opinions about the guy right now though
just leave it at that
let's focus on the wrapper let's pick up
on that because I think it's important
that you tell everyone what you told us
on the first day we met if you don't
mind my daddy's name was camouflage he
was a rapper I've been coming he was
gonna be signed to Universal Records but
two days before he was gonna sign the
contract he got murdered and yeah whoa
my whole goal is to continue my father's
legacy I feel like he died too early
that's what I feel I feel like she's
already wrapped bad things you wanted to
do
that's the story
what is this something you're gonna do
today you right - he's already making me
cry tell me what it's about
I don't know I was gonna cry today to
get here and to be in this position on
America's Got Talent
all right well good luck legit okay here
we go
[Music]
this is real life I cannot pretend to
never let him tell you what you can't do
because I have made it this far I can't
lose my struggle got something not
really went through most of them was
face to face some of them with mental
just think it my feelings oh I want to
push the pixel me to help me leave this
be so I use my utensils I'm from
Savannah it's a crab in the bucket
effect in the face they love you dad
stab you right back in the back just to
prove me wrong I get a million ego
doesn't play but the haters in the town
is gonna be family after day but I'm
just trying to get this green like a
Harper book you say you want it bad but
I wanted more and I'm like you don't got
a standby corner store cuz I'm the
greatest more and they won't be deflated
they
get it girl but taking up
this is real life I cannot pretend to
never let him tell you what you can't do
because that I made it this far
[Music]
do it
[Applause]
[Music]
dance you wrote that I just think them
the way that you write it comes from
that huh yeah you are Wow and it's not
somebody who wrote a song it's not
somebody who sings a song it's somebody
who lives a song yes yeah yeah you can't
really tell what a wonderful moment
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well Latino closure here's the good news
we provide a platform you do the hard
work I'm not an expert but I think you
the lyrics the tracks everything feels
real I'm thrilled that you come on this
show sirens I mean you know it's a good
thing what Simon's happy by your
audition I mean I have goosebumps and
I'm shaking a little bit because I want
to say something at 14 years old you
have the kind of authenticity and
honesty that some artists never achieve
in their entire lives rip yeah that's
really been a chance to have a
relationship with your father you were
not given a chance then and I want to
make sure you get a chance now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
she is amazing good for her I wanna
watch more oh man that was that was
intense
when I was 14 I was just so excited to
get close from hot topic like its life
at 14 oh my gosh my favorite kind of
rappers are raps like that you know like
raps that you can literally look at the
lyrics and go this is poetry I've not
really been a huge fan of rap music my
entire life you tell but you watch like
the Muppet musicals but the point I was
trying to get is except for in the past
maybe four so years four or five years
I've gotten more interrupt me like
that's of that type like really raw
emotion I just didn't really grow up
around that culture or listening to much
music like that but then I just feel
like I really got the experience life
and I was like oh a lot of these people
have really known some heavy stuff you
know it makes me feel so insanely
privileged in comparison I hope she
never loses that authenticity she's
gonna have a career obviously she's
gonna have a big career yeah and it's
easy to lose sight of especially it's
such a young age to lose sight of your
roots and lose sight of what made you
stand out in the first place yeah it
seems like up until this point life has
been very rough for her and very tough
and I'm just saying the ghettos and
everything in Savannah I just know from
firsthand they're no joke people live in
poverty out there it's really bad and
unfortunately things are very segregated
out there not obviously by laws but just
by you know social groups and I can know
solely sympathize just from someone who
lived there for four years like yeah
yeah Wow I went to college in Savannah
Georgia really yeah a lot of people
don't realize it's really crime ridden
out there there's a big poverty issue
hey thanks tough out here in Sherman
Oaks California - I know but I'm just
saying I understand where this girl's
coming from cuz I lived there for four
years well I had a homeless guy outside
of my 24-hour Ralph's who was very kind
mm-hmm it's tough - yeah yeah it's the
same same situation
make youtube videos yeah my rather
beginning sister story I was like oh god
here comes comes a teary-eyed party I
not no joke I kind of want to watch
America's Got Talent no just so I could
watch it so you can get to that yeah I'm
not a big reality star person a reality
TV person but I really want to see this
girl shine yeah see more what she does
and I hope she continues to write her
own music to you I know sometimes
rappers can fall off that we're like
they started hiring people to do that
for them this moment is like a golden
bottle moment yeah I just never a golden
bauble to most I just hope that as she
grows in success that she can stay
humble and stay authentic because if
we've seen too many rappers yeah it's
cool that she like her father was an
up-and-coming rapper so it's neat that
she's able to acknowledge that he was
up-and-coming and can continue on that
legacy yeah even though it sucks that he
died she can carry on his name and what
he was already building and built upon
that now this is beautiful there's a
beautiful video this is great beautiful
hopefully it's on YouTube but not
blocked
what rappers would you recommend well I
I mean I love Iggy Azalea I love Nicki
Minaj those are probably my top - I love
female rappers I gotta say and we need
more of them my girlfriend loves parties
oh yeah there's party beat oh by the way
is scary to listen to when you have a
girlfriend because oh yeah I'm just like
does she think I'm cheating on her all
the time do you think I'm just like
[ __ ] around just like tough [ __ ]
about boyfriends who suck and you really
like this song don't take it out on me
you guys can subscribe to the react
nation click that edification about the
subscribe button suck adorable Rachel
who I almost elbowed in the face check
our channel good stuff over there thanks
for being here Rachel okay let's let's
shoot a couple more things yeah
[Music]